do you guys think Americans would be
willing to lock down again because I
questioned that in my head I'm like if
they just did it all over again I don't
know no way where I live in New York
they would they're they're dying well
that's the thing blue States would
they're freaking out they were not
locked down right but people are moving
to Florida and Texas yeah and so the
blue States probably would because you
have a higher density now of the people
who want to live under the boot right
and then
South Dakota Florida Texas a bunch of
red States they wouldn't do it West
Virginia probably wouldn't do it yeah
yeah I don't know did New Hampshire Do
It
um not not it depends where because the
big cities especially with a lot of
people condensed they had their own
little versions of it but the government
is very limited in New Hampshire so it
was up to a lot of personal individuals
personal businesses to decide for
themselves but as far as comparing it to
New York it was day and night to what
was going on there